hi I'm Brianna from free code camp and
today we're going to be talking about
data speed Davis speed unlike data size
is usually measured in bits per second
whereas size is measured in bytes big
difference being bytes is eight times
bigger than bits at the very smallest
level once we start talking
exponentially that makes a really big
difference how we talk about speed kind
of depends on what we're talking about
when we talk about the speed of like an
audio download we talk about kilobits
per second kilobits not kilobytes
totally different number today we're
talking about an internet speed like the
speed that your internet service
provider gives you they usually measure
that in megabits per second so 1 million
bits per second the network speed is
something we talked about in gigabits
per second so a billion bits per second
biggest distinction here bits versus
bytes data speed is generally measured
in bits data size is measured in bytes
another thing we want to discuss just
because they have an internet speed that
says you get a certain amount of
download that doesn't mean you're going
to be able to download that many bytes
per minute per second that's just not
going to happen they're talking about
bits it's going to take you a little bit
longer to do that since your data size
is dealing with bytes